i
tiempo para nuevo repaso de la
información económica quién france24
para ello contamos una noche más con
nuestro compañero especializado jorge
hurtado bienvenido y vamos a comenzar en
eeuu donde se ha marcado un récord de
infracción este país registró la tasa de
inflación interanual en marzo más alta
de
1981 la cifra se ubicó en 85 por ciento
impulsada especialmente por los altos
costos de la energía los alimentos y la
vivienda el departamento de trabajo
informó que de febrero a marzo la
inflación subió un 1,2 por ciento el
mayor salto inter mensual desde 2005
motivado principalmente por los precios
de la gasolina y la gasolina aumentó un
48 por ciento en los últimos 12 meses
mientras que el precio de los vehículos
usados aumentaron un 35 por ciento pese
a la bajada de febrero y marzo los
inmuebles de hogar subieron un 14 7%
mientras que los comestibles han subido
un 10% incluido los aumentos del 18 por
ciento en el tocino y las naranjas los
precios de marzo es cuando se
registraron por primera vez el aumento
de precios de energía y combustibles
como consecuencia de la invasión en
ucrania el 24 de febrero el aumento de
la energía provocó el aumento también de
los costos de transporte para el envío
de mercancías en toda la economía lo que
a su vez aumenta los precios para los
consumidores el presidente job bajtín
culpó al presidente ruso vladimir putin
por el alza de los combustibles
escuchemos a los dos mayores productores
de grano del mundo china perdón ucrania
y rusia no están haciendo lo que suelen
hacer así que todo está subiendo hemos
visto datos de inflación de hoy el 70
por ciento del aumento de los precios en
marzo vino desde la subida de los
precios de la gasolina de putin
gastón pero jorge que más ha influido en
esta tendencia al alza de la inflación y
hasta cuándo puede durar bueno como
recordarán durante la pandemia obligó al
cierre de decenas de empresas en ese
país que terminaron con 22 millones de
puestos laborales y la economía entró en
una recesión pero la recuperación al
igual que la pandemia fue inesperada
grandes inyecciones de ayuda
gubernamental y la intervención de
emergencia de la reserva federal que
redujo los tipos de interés entre otras
cosas ayuda a que las empresas y
ciudadanos buscarán reactivar la
normalidad a mediados de 2021 la llegada
de las vacunas también ayudó a que los
consumidores regresaran a los
restaurantes a los bares a las tiendas a
los aeropuertos y a los lugares de ocio
pero las empresas o la oferta del
mercado no pudo con el ritmo de la
inesperada demanda de los ciudadanos no
contrataron personal con suficiente
rapidez tampoco los suministros fueron
suficientes para responder a los pedidos
de los clientes fue entonces rodrigo
como recordarás cuando vimos los puertos
y los almacenes de carga sin capacidad
las cadenas de suministro globales
sufrieron grandes atascos ese
desequilibrio efecto de la pandemia se
convirtió en elevada inflación y ahora
se le suma un nuevo elemento la guerra
de ucrania que aumentó los costos de los
combustibles para muchos expertos podría
durar mientras las empresas se esfuercen
por satisfacer la demanda de bienes y
servicios de los consumidores y para eso
pues todavía no tenemos fecha y en medio
de todo este contexto bélico el banco
mundial ha aprobado nuevas ayudas para
ucrania el presidente del banco mundial
david malpass aseguró que también
ayudarán a los países en desarrollo
luchan contra los altos precios de los
alimentos y la energía- el banco prepara
un paquete de apoyo de 1500 millones de
dólares para ucrania durante un
encuentro en la escuela de economía de
varsovia el funcionario dijo que el
banco estaba ayudando a ucrania a
prestar servicios críticos como el pago
de los salarios de los trabajadores de
los hospitales las pensiones y los
programas sociales producto de la guerra
el banco mundial pronosticó que oakland
y reduciría la producción económica este
año en un 45% y que la mitad de las
empresas en ese país ya están cerradas a
escuchemos
no son nunca tantos países habían
experimentado la recesión a la vez
sufriendo la pérdida de capital empleos
y medios de vida al mismo tiempo la
inflación sigue acelerándose reduciendo
los ingresos reales de los hogares de
todo el mundo especialmente los pobres
org porque acabamos con los principales
indicadores de las bolsas de valores
bueno como era de esperarse wall street
cerró en rojo por los temores de la
inflación y las posibles consecuencias
del aumento de los tipos de interés de
parte de la reserva federal de eeuu en
europa el dax 40 de fráncfort cerró en
negativo por los malos signos de la
guerra de ucrania en américa latina' de
la bolsa mexicana de valores perdió un
1,2 por ciento en su principal indicador
en su séptima jornada en terreno
negativo algo que no se veía desde julio
del 2020 mal día desde luego para la
economía mundial gracias jorge por este
repaso a nuestros espectadores les
invitamos a que sigan conectados con
nosotros en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]